ici à washington le dispositif de
sécurité est en train d'être levés petit
à petit on voit de moins en moins deux
barrages de police les membres de la
garde nationale sont en train de quitter
la capitale fédérale mais il reste
encore quelques-uns d'entre eux qui sont
déployés ici notamment près de la maison
blanche où il on peut maintenant accéder
aux bâtiments officiels en tout cas on
peut s'en approcher ce qui n'était pas
le cas ces derniers jours de son côté
joe biden a donc pris ses quartiers au
sein de la maison blanche pour lancer un
certain nombre de mesures visant
notamment à détricoter un certain nombre
de politiques lancées par
l'administration trump mais le chantier
principal qui attend le job hayden c'est
de tenter de réconcilier cette amérique
profondément divisé on voit déjà les
premières oppositions se mettre en place
par exemple lorsque joe biden a annoncé
des mesures sur l'immigration mais celle
qui a provoqué le plus de réactions
c'est le fait que les états unis
réintègre l'accord de paris sur le
climat beaucoup de réactions de
l'opposition notamment celle du sénateur
républicain du texas tech crous qui est
aussi un proche de donald trump on
écoute
en signant ce décret le président biden
montrent qu'ils s'intéressent plus aux
opinions des citoyens de paris qu aux
emplois des citoyens de pittsburgh
rejoindre la corde paris ne consiste pas
à restaurer le leadership américain à
l'étranger ou à résoudre la crise
climatique mais il s'agit plutôt des
projets des démocrates de détruire les
emplois qu'ils n'aiment pas y compris
des milliers d'emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier et perdre le contrôle de
nos énergies futures
le procureur général du texas qui a même
déjà fait savoir qu'ils pourraient
lancer des procédures en justice pour
contester des décisions de joe biden
certaines organisations texane craignent
justement les répercussions de la
politique environnementale du nouveau
locataire de la maison blanche sur
l'économie de cet état du texas qui est
très liée à l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles du côté des
supporters de donald trump forcément un
peu de déception en ce moment certains
espéraient un ultime retournement de
situation le jour de l'investiture un
retournement de situation qui n'a pas eu
lieu alors il ya quand même eu quelques
petits rassemblements ces derniers jours
de la part d'un certain nombre de
supporters
trump notamment devant les capitales de
certains états du pays veut maintenant
les regards se tournent vers la floride
l'endroit où séjourne actuellement
donald trump beaucoup se demandent ce
cas imprévu l'ancien locataire de la
maison blanche ici on parle dieu la
possible création d'un parti politique
le patriote parti qu'il pourrait lancer
en vue de rester en politique et
pourquoi pas tenter sa chance pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 24 ce
qui est sûr c'est que parmi les quelque
74 millions d'électeurs de donald trump
beaucoup continuent à le soutenir alors
vous l'aurez compris malgré les appels à
l'unité nationale lancé lors de la
cérémonie d'investiture par joe biden
l'arrêt que la réconciliation de
l'amérique diviser ce n'est pas pour
tout de suite